first off I'm very curious about working
on a movie of this size with a director
who is making his very first feature
were you concerned about that at all and
how did David surprise you you know I
was lucky you were just mentioning when
we met in Sundance I had already worked
with the first-time directors and I
worked with a lot of female first-time
directors and so I kind of had an
experience of working with first-time
directors and it's different obviously
dynamic but David felt like so well
Slyke experience and I mean obviously he
works closely with Tim Miller and has
blur films with him and he's no stranger
to this he's been doing stuff really
embedded in in the industry he's been
building trailers and has a sense of
direction so not only that he had such a
clarity on his vision which I thought
was really impressive for just in
general not for a first-time director
but just for a person he just had a
clarity and I an idea and he was really
invested I'm like making the characters
real and emotional and not just like one
layered especially cared about the
female character which I loved and his
rare because it didn't feel like he
didn't want her to be either a damsel in
distress or just a tough chick he wanted
to really kind of blend these two things
together and I was sold immediately
after my first meeting and it was just
from there like that never disappointed
I'm glad you brought that up about your
character because I I was reading the
press notes and I was surprised that
they described the relationship between
Katy and Ray as just a romance it almost
feels like unfair to boil it down to
that specific descriptor so in your own
words can you explain what's going on
between these I think it's more a
platonic love which I think it's strong
because that was one of the things that
kind of brought me into this film which
was like oh I don't have to be anyone's
love interest this is amazing you know
and it is I do believe in love
relationship that's important in films
just because it creates a we connect
with love we created with emotions and I
think it is important we do things based
on love but the greatest thing about
this was just it wasn't like a random
version of it it was sort of like these
two people that feel feel unseen
and kind of see each other in a
different way but it's kind of a Romeo
and Juliet situation where she can't
help him and vice versa and I loved that
she was just an integral part of the
story in the sense of she's the heart of
the story she is emotional she is real
she is she doesn't have an agenda which
is rare also next week films for female
like I had never had the chance to be my
independent version of itself like it's
always like attached to some version of
a male and she is a different thing in
this film so I felt really strong and
the fact that she stands up for what she
believes and it's a nod to real female
soldiers because they are going out
there and she is a female soldier and I
had to do it right towards them yeah it
comes through very very well I was very
impressed by that element also I wanted
to ask about the breathing because I go
to the gym a lot one of the worst things
that I do at the gym is I don't breathe
properly so did playing this particular
role make you really focus on that to
the point that you've taken it with you
yes it was and I've you know throughout
the we did very z-rotation
iterations of the the story because for
a long time you know my breathing was
crucial because I thought you know that
really gives away from me it was
important to give away with the
breathing when she was lying she
couldn't lie so the breathing is kind of
what gave her away and it was a regular
and you feeling like she does certain
breathe breath set you're like oh that's
odd she's breathing
abnormally here and there and then when
you kind of come back you're like oh she
was not being able to lie and so that
was super important obviously the tone
of my voice is so deep because it has to
match kind of the problem with the lungs
that it was tricky because I didn't want
to sound flat but I also wanted to keep
that that range of her voice so it was
tricky I really went these are all
subtle things obviously they're not big
maybe for some people but for me was a
challenging and obviously the choking
scene was really hard because I had to
choke and so we did that a lot of times
and that was it really got me to the
emotion too because that's a scary
feeling it was worth thinking about all
the attention to detail here because it
played very well I appreciate that